hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played by me just a
few minutes ago I played a bullet game
on leeches and it turned out a a really
really good game like a really really
nice one and I I'm really proud of it I
really want to show it to you guys as
the title suggests I accidentally found
a forced Checkmate in six I didn't I
wasn't looking for checkmate and I
wasn't uh I mean I was hoping to give
Checkmate I didn't see it I just you
know ended up playing it uh and uh I
thought it was a very nice game so let's
check it out um and my opponent is let
me just check my opponent is uh
rated some 20 2236 on leeches and I was
22.74 at the time I played this so let's
check it out uh here my opponent played
Ponte E4 and I need for uh if I'm not
you know testing anything or if I'm uh
trying to actually win a game I play uh
the Scandinavian defense so I played
Ponte D5 he played e captures on D5
Queen captures by me and now Knight to
C3 and I usually go for queen six so
this is what I played here Knight to F3
we have Knight to F6 D4 and Ponte A6 so
this is the standard setup that I use
when playing the Scandinavian I also
made a tutorial on it if you guys are
interested you can check it out it will
also be in the description below we we
have Pawn to G3 he of course goes for
the yes also standard setup he wants to
play Bishop to G2 and chase away my
queen with a bishop to F4 and here you
should play Bishop to G4 I I switched
the move order a little bit I played
Knight to C6 and now after Bishop to F4
I played Queen to B4 and this is already
quite bad for black but the problem is
if he doesn't know what to play here and
I've played the hundreds and hundreds of
times No One Ever Knows What to play at
least on this level uh you should always
punish black with A3 here even if it
doesn't uh necessarily win you anything
A3 is just uh devastating for for black
black and pretty much never capture the
video Pawn here after A3 you can't
capture sorry you cannot capture because
Knight A4 traps the queen and if you go
back Queen to B6 already D5 comes in
white will have an excellent game for
example Knight to d8 you will get Knight
to the E5 and the black will really
struggle that to even find moves here
but okay my opponent luckily for me did
not know this he played Rook to B1 he
just defended his Pawn as okay this is a
bullet game one plus zero so not a lot
of time to think and I continued the
game with Bishop to G4 and from this
moment on it's actually a real really
nice game uh so uh of course Bishop
captures on C7 white doesn't really have
time for this is Bishop captures I can
just capture on F3 and then gobble up
the D4 pawn attack the queen attack the
C2 Pawn so this will be uh pretty bad so
instead he just played Bishop to G2 he
continued developing and I played Queen
side castles now my opponent does play
D5 but now I no longer care I play Pawn
to E5 attack is Bishop of course he
cannot capture the Knight because of
Queen captures on D1 so he played Bishop
to D2 and now I played Pawn to E4 and my
position is already winning at this
point uh it's only a matter of how you
do it my opponent played Knight at E2 he
uh is now threatening to attack my queen
and he's of course thinking next he's
gonna deal with the Knight on F3 but I
just play e captures on F3 I give up my
queen because I will be getting quite a
lot in return so he played Bishop
captures on B4 I played F characters and
G2 attacking his Rook so he has to do
something about that or Rook to G1 and
now Knight captures on B4 I could also
capture with the bishop I don't know why
I thought maybe
uh it would be more potent the the
capture with the knight uh but okay even
if he attacks that I can always
recapture here so uh I don't know uh for
some reason I captured with the Knight
we have Pawn to F3 he wants the free FDF
to square for his King and I play Rook
captures on D5 I attack his queen queen
to C1 and now Bishop captures on F3 he
does move the king king F2 and okay he
still uh I did win a lot of material but
he still has a queen we have Bishop to
H5 and now Knight to F4 he's attacking
my rook and Bishop and now I go for the
kill Knight the E4 with check King
captures and G2 and The Rook to D2 check
now he he could give up his Queen and
it's probably the best movie he he can
play here uh but here okay his position
would be just the Lost he's done too
much material so instead uh after this
Rook the B2 check he played King to H3
King the H1 just loses the bishop to F3
checks so nothing going on there so King
to H3 and now Knights the F2 with check
uh now I'm running his game of the board
he played King to H4 and now there's
actually a force made in six that I
found accidentally so feel free to pause
the video and try to find this uh
wonderful mating sequence while I give
you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
wonderful mating six and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is best of the E7 check this is what I
played as I felt it that okay if he
captures the bishop then the king will
be in trouble but it's wonderful how uh
you know the the the the the the length
to what this white king goes to to try
to escape is just a really really
awesome King captures on H5 I played G6
check King to H6 now comes Knight to G4
check only moves King to G7 so this is
what he played he attacks my Rook but
now Bishop to F6 check uh checks the
king and it defends The Rook here he
played King captures on F7 and now it's
a mating two I played Rook to D7 check
he played King D6 and I finished it with
Rook to E8 Checkmate so I played this
and I was like wow that was that was a
very nice Scandinavian and even though
okay I did mess up at the move order and
I allowed him after Queen to B4 to play
this A3 move which would give me a
really bad position uh but after he
played Rook to B1 it was all very very
nice there so once again I really like
this line uh for the Scandinavian this
this setup with um after let's say Pawn
to E6 displayed this setup with Queen to
D6 Knight to F6 Pawn to A6 it's just
very very natural to play and the the
moves just come very very easy like
Knight to C6 Bishop death five or Bishop
to G4 sometimes you can even play Queen
to B4 you can even give up this uh C7
Pawn in the G3 Bishop to F4 line but not
in this specific line that I played so
it's a very nice if you guys uh you know
uh want to try out something else
against D4 uh do check it out so first
link in the description below will be
this game that I played on leeches if
you want to go over it and analyze it
yourselves and the second link will be
my tutorial on how to play this
Scandinavian setup if you guys are
interested in that uh so yeah that's the
game I hope you guys enjoyed it a bit of
a short one but I I enjoyed it so much I
just wanted to share it with you so yeah
that that's pretty much it I would like
to thank rajashri chaudhuri Robert Bloom
Andrew woolly an anonymous person in
Grizzly chessfestival.org.gg for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
uh feeder World rapid Team Championship
uh until it finishes so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day